it was a straightforward answer to what
might have been a difficult question why
is Germany managing to keep its death
rate lower than we are we all know that
Germany got ahead in terms of its
ability to do testing for the virus and
there's a lot to learn from that and
we've been trying to learn the lessons
from that the government has promised a
ramp up our testing regime it set an
ambitious total of 100,000 tests a day
by the end of April but Germany is
already testing around 50,000 people a
day on tests there were 14,000 in a
single day and so that shows progress
we've had 7500 NHS workers and their
families tested and we've got nine
drive-thru sites currently operational
Philly more work to do but important
that we've made the progress we have so
far the total number of people in the UK
tested for coronavirus since the
beginning of the outbreak is just over
two hundred and thirteen thousand but
that's only around nought point three
percent of the population Germany by
comparison has tested almost 1 million
of its people management of their health
infrastructure and a realization that
they needed to have this this set of
laboratories in place in order to be
able to respond quickly
I think it's arguable the public health
health England were quite slow to
respond certainly compared to their
counterparts in Germany Germany has
followed the South Korean model of
widespread testing and contact tracing
it moved quickly right at the very start
and was helped by an advanced public
healthcare system the mass testing
identified covered 19 carriers who were
then isolated to stop the spread of the
virus
it has recorded just over 1,900 Kovach
19 deaths in the UK that figure is more
than three times higher Professor Witte
says lessons are being learned from
Germany's response to this pandemic we
all hope these lessons don't prove to
cost
Aashish Joshi Sky News